Okay. So it's 1970s, and I'm getting my doctorate
in theoretical chemistry from
Harvard. And I'm watching Nova programmes on this ground breaking work
on training animals to communicate with humans – work on signing chimps and dolphin studies –
and I decide that's it, I've had this epiphany, I'm going to change my whole field and do this work.
And I'm going to do it with
a parrot. Parrots talk, they live for a long time! I thought this was the most
incredible idea in the world. That I'd be part of this, this revolution. I finished
the degree. I study up. Everything I can in the field. I write my grant proposal I
submit it thinking yes.
And no. The reviewers come back asking me what I'm smoking. [laughter] The last
time parrots and humans were connected – unlike apes where we're connected, you know, pretty closely genetically –
280 million years ago. All right, you know, big big difference.
Um, parrots, unlike dolphins, they have this little tiny brain the size of a shelled walnut. You know, dolphins have this
big brain, it makes sense to work with them. Not with a
parrot. Plus, I'm working with an animal that's a pet.
You know, I mean, how am I going to keep my scientific objectivity there? And plus –
I'm not going to use the standard scientific techniques of the day, which means starve your animal
to 80% of its normal body weight, stick in a Skinner box and go from there. [laughter] No, no, I'm going to just talk
right. Even my
bird. Yeah, right. Even my then-husband, who is a neurophysiologist, says, "No, no Irene.
no, no, Irene, until you can stick an electrode in its head and get a P300, it's not science. And I look at him blankly, cause like you
look at him blankly, 'cause, like you, I'm saying, "A P300, what's he's talking about?"
Okay. So I, but I- I'm really determined, I go out and I buy
a parrot, it's a grey parrot – that's the name of the species and the color – he's a grey, different shades of grey,
bright red tail, weighs – he's about this big – weighs about a pound, I name him Alex
for Avian Learning
experiment." [laughter]
And so I started training him, by modeling ?system?. He's learning a couple
labels and I- I put in the grant proposal. And this time I'm really lucky, I have somebody on
the panel who studies birdsong – who recognizes the striking parallels between
the development of vocal communication in birds and humans.
So I get a grant for a year. Now, most grants are for 3 or 4 years, because, if you get it for a year
as soon as you get the grant, you have to resubmit it, and, you know, you have to get some data in between there. But I ?figured?, no –
we are on our way, this is gonna work.
Well, it wasn't quite that simple. Um, Alex and m- my life were more like "The Perils of Pauline"
than anything else, 'cause any time anything great happened, there was always something that then happened
to bring us back down, and it was quite a rollercoaster
of a life, but at the beginning we started this work. And in Alex's first 10 years he
learned about, oh, about 50 labels for objects. He learned to label 7 colors.
He learned to label 5 shapes – 2-, 3-, 4-, 5- and 6-
cornered. He labeled different materials, he understood concepts, so I could show him the object and
I'd say, "Alex," you know, "What's this?"
And he'd say, "Block." And I'd – "Good birdy, an- and what color?" "Blue." "Good boy, and what shape?"
"4 corner." "And what matter?" "Wood."
And he combined these labels, so he could identify 150 different things. This is a
parrot, brain size of shelled walnut, could label that 150 different things. He learned concepts of
bigger and smaller. So I could show him two things and say, "What color bigger? What color smaller?" and he'd tell me.
He learned, and this was really extraordinary, concept of same and different.
So I could show him two things, and not just tell me that they were same or different,
but he could tell me what about them was same or different.
So I'd say, "What same?" and he'd tell me color, shape, matter or none – if nothing
were same or different. And this was pretty exciting work, and, again Alex was about
10-years-old, and I'm invited to the International Primatological Congress. This is
a big deal. International Congress, I'm speaking in front of 1,000
people, and I'm the only person there who is not a primatologist.
I am the one person who has been invited to talk on comparative behavior. And I'm talking
And I'm talking about a bird – again, brain size of shelled walnut – to all these people who are working with apes
and orangutans and whatever.
So I get up and I give my talk. At the end of my talk, one of the sil-, we call them the silverback males,
and one of the [laughter and applause]
one of the senior, you know, senior primatologists gets up, and I'm going, "Okay, here it comes," you know, "I'm just going
to get totally creamed." And he, you know, [clears throat and feigns British accent]
"Well, you know, ver- very, very interesting little study you did there, um, but you mean to tell
me that your bird did something much more complicated than ?premax? apes?" And
I want to say, "Yeah, I'm backwards and in heels, you know, to be honest."[laughter]
But I- I say, "No," and I smile, I say, "No sir," you know, "That's right, sir, he did," and, and I'm thinking, "Okay,"
and he says, "Oh!" and he sits down. And I'm going, "[exclaims] I've done it! I've made it." You know? Yay! Except,
you know, I should have been, you know, drinking gallons of champagne at that point.
But a couple of weeks earlier I had gotten this letter from the National Science Foundation saying, "You know what?
It was a nice proposal, but we ran out
of money, so, no more funding." So I'm sitting there going, "Okay? How are we going to keep the
lab going at this point?" So here's Alex doing this great
stuff, and you are having some troubles with the funding, and this was, this again, this was the story of
our lives.
So we fast forward a little bit, and it was still very hard for me to get some
recognition from colleagues, even wi- with these successes. There was always the question of
scientific objectivity. And I dealt with it by treating Alex like a colleague, um,
the way I would treat my students. You know, you work
with them, you teach them as much as you can, you respect
them. But you- you draw a line between the way you interact with them and the way you interact
with- with your own children, or the way you'd interact with your significant
others, to keep that scientific
objectivity. And, it wasn't – didn't always stick. I mean, when my marriage fell apart
and I was getting- getting a divorce. And it comes down to dividing the property, and my husband says, "Well, you
take the bird and I'll take the dog." And part of me is going, "Hey, cool," you know, "no fights with him
about the bird," but the other part of me's going, "Alex isn't a pet, like our dog!"
You know, "He's my scientific center!" You know, "How could you say this?" but,
you know, we're- we're doing okay, and- and, again, by this time we're doing a lot of publicity, we're doing Scientific
American Frontiers and Discovery Channel and 48 Hours and
Alex is about 15, and we get a, um, invitation to do radio from the BBC.
And by this time, Alex's personality is really coming to a
fore, because he's learned not just to answer questions, but to label and to interact and ask
me questions. And, so now I'm – I'm got this radio, and I'm thinking, "Radio?" You know,
I could ask him anything, and I could say, "Yes, good boy!" because, you know, they can't see what- what's going on. [laughter]
So I think, "Alright, how am I going to do this?" So I go, "Okay." So I think, so I start the program I say, "Okay, I'm holding
an orange, square piece of wood, and I'm going to ask Alex some questions." So you hear my heels,
"click click click" as I go into the room, and I go, "Alex! Going to ask you some questions, going to do some work!" And I go, "Alex,
what color?" And little birdy voice, "No, you tell me what shape." [laughter]
"Oh, okay, Alex, it's 4 corner, now, can you tell me what
color?" "Tell me what matter." [laughter] "Okay, Alex,
it's wood, can you tell me what color?" "No, how many?" [laughter]
"Alex, there's one toy here." And- and, you know, part of me, again, is going, "Oh, this is so cool!
He's not just acting like a little robot. And he's interacting with me, he's talking with me." The other part of me is going,
"Um, but they really want to hear him answer some questions." So I'm going, "Alex, come on, what color?" and he goes,
"No, tell me what shape," and I go, "Okay, Alex, timeout. You're misbehaving," and you hear my heels
as I start to walk out the door, giving him a timeout, and then comes a little birdy voice.
"I'm sorry. Come here! Orange." [laughter]
So
obviously, I treated Alex like a colleague, but he didn't necessarily treat me like a
colleague. And, again, we had, you know, we had some ups, we had some downs. I was
at Arizona at that point, we left Arizona for a number of reasons, we got a gig at the Media Lab at MIT.
Those of you who know – you're local, you know that, what that is. Big time. I'm
hired for temporary
position, um, that could be extended, to do – use the bird as a model
for intelligent learning systems.
But once I'm there and I start looking at all the gizmos and whatever they have, I start developing, for
the sponsors,
animal-human communication systems – to enrich the birds lives, all these animals.
InterPet Explorer, web browsers for parents, things like that. And tho- those of you who know the Media Lab
know that the sponsors come – who've given us all this money to do these
things – come twice a year to see what we've done with their money.
Well, word had gotten out that there was a live bird. And they wanted to see
Alex. And they come through in waves, 5 to 7 minutes. And I was setting up the InterPet
thing, and like, "No no no no, we want to see Alex do
his phonemes!" And I'm going, "Oh, whatever you guys want, you know, I'll do it. Phonemes!" What we were
doing was showing him refrigerator letters – the things y-you show your kids to have them sound out
the letters – in the hope that somewhere down the road we could put the letters together and he
could maybe sound out a label? To see if he understood what these sounds meant.
Okay, so, but he's at this very early stage! And the task at this point, we put all
the letters on a tray. They're different colors.
And then, you know, we ask Alex, "What color is, you know, ["s" sound]?" You know. And he goes, "Blue." "Good birdy."
"Want a nut.""Okay, Alex, you can't have a nut, we've only got these people for 5 minutes!" Um, you know,
let's do another thing, okay, you know,
"What sound is green?" "["sh" sound]." "S.H., good birdy." "Want a nut!"
"Wait, wait." So, we do this several times, and each time he's getting more and more upset
because he's not getting his reward. And finally, after about 4 or 5 times, he looks at me, he goes, want nut!
Nnn uh tuh. [laughter]
["n" sound] ["u" sound] ["t" sound]." [laughter]
And, in typical Alex, you know, I'm thinking, okay, he's telling me, "Stupid, do I have to
spell it for you?" But the other part of it is, you
know, I'm thinking, he's gone light years
ahead of us! Because ["n" sound] and ["t" sound] were on the tray, but ["u" sound] was
not! So he had figured out –
himself – how to split the words apart, into the sounds, and use them. And this- this was the type of
thing that was going on.
on. So, aga- again, after all of these high points, you know, the Media Lab gig
falls apart, um,
I'm actually on unemployment for a while, I get a, a Radcliffe Fellowship to help
things through. But to keep the lab going, I'm going to bird clubs every other
weekend, to – literally, to raise money, I have to raise $100,000 a year to keep the lab going.
And it's getting more and more crazy, and we're trying to figure out what's going on, and my colleagues at Harvard have this
great
idea that Alex has been so interactive and fun, maybe we should start looking at how he
sees the world. Literally. Can he do optical illusions?
So we put together a grant, and, of course, it's rejected the first time, we fix it up, we resubmit
it. And it's September 2001, and the grant is approved and funded.
Okay, not for the 3 years, of course, that we asked for, but for a
year. So I'm really excited, because, you know, I'm thinking, "History!" Okay, again, just
like before. We'd had some data, I knew I could resubmit it, everything would be fine.
Things are turning around, and a little bit later that week I'm sitting at my desk, eating breakfast, which
I do, emails are coming in from Europe and- and
Japan. And one comes in from Europe, ?italk? has been funded. Yay, yay!
Okay. It's a big European consortium, millions of euros coming through for
this, I'm a consultant, no real money but they send me to Europe once a year,
again, to use Alex as a model for intelligent learning systems, and I'm thinking, again, "Yes!"
Justification of our work. We're on an upswing. I'm so excited. Get a second cup of
coffee, sit down, and there's another email with the tag "Sad news from the head vet
at Brandeis," where the birds are.
And I'm thinking, Okay, you know, some technician, there might be a problem, you know, in the family, somebody sick, we're
going to get flowers, it's a, it's a standard thing. And I open this email.
But it's not exactly about a tech, except that one found a dead parrot in the back
left hand corner of the room. And I freeze. And I'm going, this- this,
this is not true, it can't be, I mean, this is, this is a nightmare, right? I'm going to wake up. But I call Brandeis and,
no, Alex has passed in the night. And I go into complete shock, 'cause,
'cause this is a bird, he's now 30-years-old, we're supposed to have another 20 years here.
And I can't, I can't believe it. I mean, obviously. I'm not functioning.
Um, I kept a diary but, I- I can, you
know. It's hard to even talk about it now,
but, um, so over the weekend friends come up, they drive from Washington to be there with
me to make sure I'm fed, to roll me into bed, so I can – I won't sleep but, to get some rest.
Other friends locally are taking care of me to make my board of directors from the foundation
sets up an obituary, because I- I can't, I mean, I'm just totally out of it. I- I'm like
walking into
walls. And Monday morning comes, and I call the Brandeis um
PR folks, the folks I've been working with for all these years – because every time Alex had done something cool,
the media would pick up on
it, and they would, you know, there'd be this little thing of-
of stuff, and we- we'd do some interviews. And so I call them, an- and ?Lara?, my friend
there, says, "Irene, I- I'll let, I'll put this out, but, you know, this is a bird. I mean, it's not going to get any
traction, but I'll put it out." And I say, "Fine,
whatever." And by the time I drive the 40 minutes from my house to-
to Brandeis, my cell phone is ringing off the hook, my lab manager's cell phone's ringing off the hook,
the lab, ?his? phone is ringing off the hook. We're being asked for interviews all over the
world. And I'm, you know, interview mode I can handle. I've done this for years.
Pick up phone. You know, close eyes, answer questions as
they come, hang up phone, take the next interview, fine. That I can deal with.
And I'm doing this for a week. Meanwhile, emails are pouring in, 3,000 to my own account.
Boxes and boxes of letters are coming from people all over the world. Alex gets 3
articles in The New York Times, an obituary in The Economist. I mean, you
know, [laughter] yeah! World leaders, not- not a parrot. And I'm
still in- in total shock, it's just nothing's coming through. And finally, I get this- this
big box of letters, but there's a little box inside, and I open it up, and it's from grade
school
class. And the week before Alex died, the teacher had brought her grey parrot into
the classroom to teach them about animal intelligence and conservation issues. And when
the kids learned about Alex's death, they said they all wanted to write sympathy notes.
So they
all drew pictures of Alex. And then – little notes to me.
And I'm opening one of these, and it's from a little boy, and he
says, "I know how you feel. My grandma died this summer. And someday your heart will heal."
And that's when this- this, all these barriers that I had put up – to
keep Alex
on the other side of my emotions, so I could do the science – it came through
that there wasn't going to be any more science. Alex was gone. And all these emotions
broke through. And I realized I had lost the most important being in my life. Thank you.
[Applause]